Cara Santa Maria is the host and
producer of the talk nerdy podcast
co-host of the skeptics guide to the
universe LA area Emmy award-winning
reporter for SoCal connected on KCET and
science correspondent for tech now on al
Jazeera America but most importantly
she's my friend Kara welcome to the show
hey man your resume is blowing up huh
getting kind of crazy you got a lot of
stuff going on all sides e stuff and you
are my science e girl I'm gonna go too
yeah you are Mike go do so I thought
you'd be a perfect second guest at my
show because you know we had Sam Harris
on last week also scientist also a
scientist actually like really a
scientist I'm not really a scientist
like Sam is is he more of a scientist d
yeah Sam Sam actually finished the PhD
he took time off to write his first book
but then he actually went back and
finished I took time off and just kept
taking time off so I got the master yeah
but you're my science girl I know that
communicator all right you are our
science communicators that's where I
wanted to start actually because right
under your name right now it says
science communicator so what is a
science communicator you know I think
more than anything is just a catch-all
term that a lot of people in my
profession use so it could mean that you
communicate science as an author maybe
you're a blogger maybe you give talks
maybe you do what I do which is more in
front of the camera work or even some
production work behind it so sometimes
it takes a more journalistic flair
sometimes it takes more of an
entertainment Flair and those are two
very different camps but it all falls
within that science communication
umbrella I mean the main goal is to help
communicate scientific principles to the
public help improve science literacy and
do a little bit of translation because
sometimes scientists aren't very good at
liaison with the public sometimes
they're amazing and I love that
sometimes they need a little bit of help
and so that's that's where people like I
come in right and I think sometimes
people on my side of it need help and
that's why I always bring you on to
clean up some of the scientific messes
I'm better at and English but you you
helped me clean up some that stuff so
obviously we have some of our old
audience that's going to here have heard
some of what we're gonna do here but we
have a whole bunch of new people that I
think are gonna really dig this so I
want to get to the science stuff later
but I wanna start with atheism sure
because you're also my main 80
you and Jacqueline Glen are my two main
atheist so first off why don't we do
some basic definitions here this might
be tough it's gonna be tough I think you
can handle
atheism agnosticism is if you just break
down the word it's not knowing right a
lot of people self-identify as agnostics
if they say I'm not sure if there's a
greater power I'm not sure what happens
after you die and I don't want to hedge
any bets now I personally think that the
label agnostic is redundant because you
know whether you're atheistic or
theistic whether you're a believer or
non-believer I said those backwards
nobody knows if you claim to know like
you're full of [ __ ] you know you know
things I don't know you don't have
powers I don't have I don't the people
who scream about at the most they
usually seem to know the least yeah
actually there are some studies that
that confirm that so so I think of
myself as an agnostic or I'm sorry an
atheistic agnostic and some people are
theistic agnostics meaning that I you
know don't factor God into my daily life
I simply do not believe that God exists
yeah I know you to be a pretty moral a
pretty forthright person and I how do
you that's very nice of you to say but
but how do you navigate the sort of
moral divide if you're not getting it
from from some old book with some
numbers right because I was raised
Mormon too let's not forget we're
getting to that and then I left the
church so not only I'm like more of a
heathen I'm kind of the worst criminal
within the church's viewpoint because I
actually accepted Jesus was baptized and
then rejected it which is way worse than
never having it to begin with right
where do I get morals I get morals from
literature I get morals from ethics
courses I get morals from you know
empathy I get morals from interacting
with people and looking at their
struggles and and trying to put myself
in people's shoes and trying to
understand the human experience I mean
we are innately empathetic creatures we
are innate
moral creatures and the more that we can
kind of embrace others the more that we
can try to I think remove the us them
paradigm which is also very human and
it's also very difficult to push past
but the more that we do that I think the
more that we can live these moral lives
and a lot of people want to say that
morality is sort of a an outcome of
religion perhaps a religion is an
outcome of morality sure there are
correlations between the two but as I
often say when we talk about science
correlation does not imply causality
there's no way to prove that without
religion we wouldn't have or that you
know that yeah without religion we
wouldn't have a moral compass and it's
actually pretty philosophically
ludicrous to think in those terms right
so okay so you are from Texas as you
just said you grew up Mormon so in the
Mormon Church when did you come out yeah
so if I'm remembering correctly I came
out when I was around 15 years old and
it was you consider it like coming out I
mean how did the identity girl Cara how
did she feel about like actually having
to say this thing and that's the thing I
actually had to say it because I wasn't
I didn't grow up in kind of a sort of
religious household I grew up in a very
traditional Mormon household so I
remember telling my father I had been
questioning for a while and he had been
giving me kind of the Pat responses of
like you know pray about it and whatever
you'll figure it out on your own sure
and when it I would pray about it and
nothing would happen and then I was like
what am i doing
I finally remember telling my father you
know I don't believe I don't believe and
I feel like I'm lying myself going to
church every Sunday every Wednesday
every day before school going to
seminary it was a huge part of my life
and it felt like a big ruse I think much
like somebody who is in the closet and
who is struggling trying to act straight
or trying to be somebody that they're
not and so I remember telling him and I
remember these words as long as you live
under my roof I have a moral obligation
to God to force you to go to church
until you're 18
years old Wow so what do you do with
that as a 15 year old I didn't live
under his roof anymore really so it was
a big choice you know my parents had
long been divorced and at 15 I remember
saying to him you know technically I
think I'm of an age of consent where if
we went to the courthouse and I pled my
case that a judge would say she can stay
with her mom full-time it's her choice
she's you know she's old enough to make
these kinds of decisions and I was a
pretty precocious kid I'm sure I could
have convinced the judge that I had
thought about this quite a bit which I
had and so my father said okay he let me
make that choice it was a difficult bind
to be in and I didn't talk to him for
many years after that Wow our
relationship took a big hit and yeah it
took a long time for us to get back on
good terms yeah so there's two really
different but interesting pieces to that
because there's the choice that you made
in your own life to say this is who I am
but then there's this other piece of
it's not easy for it for a 40 year old
to say to their parent I don't believe
in what you believe much less a 15 year
old sure it's maybe it's even easier for
a 15 year old because you're like
rebellious at that point anyway I mean
I'm not sure but that definitely I look
back at the gravity of that decision and
I think like whoa that was pretty bold
of me yeah I'm not sure if I felt that
way at the time yeah how do you separate
one of the things we talked with Sam
about a lot was separating the doctrine
of something from the people that follow
it so in the case with Sam it was mostly
about the doctrine of Islam versus
Muslim people so how do you know after
the experience that you had with your
father believing what you believe your
whole career really is is very much
based in this how do you separate the
doctrine of Mormonism I'm sure you have
many other family members that you love
that are great people and all that how
do you separate that from the piece of
you that says I just don't believe in
any of this yeah you know I think it's
it's for me it's easy to separate for my
own life right like I can look at
Mormonism and I can look at my beliefs
and I can say that's [ __ ] and I
don't believe in it but of course there
are people that I love who are like hook
line and sinker they buy into it and
it's one thing to step back and say you
know they bought into [ __ ] but it's
another thing to actually say I still
respect these people in their will ed
yeah you know I don't come yes I come
from Texas I don't come from like
rednecks
yeah you know my mother who's no longer
more men is an educator she's a
schoolteacher recently retired my father
who still is very much Mormon is an
engineer and his wife who is also very
much Mormon is a science teacher a very
good science teacher and so these are
educated people who promote education
and who are very good parents adopted
you know adult not adult but teenage
children after we have moved out of the
house like incredible people yeah and I
love them dearly but we have a big
disconnect when it comes to belief now I
don't think they need to believe what I
believe for us to get along and
vice-versa it's one thing when you're in
a parental child situation the rules are
a bit different but it is still tough
because I think one of the things that
you take with you no matter how long
after the reconciliation happens is a
bit of pity a bit of like I I know in my
heart of hearts that I kind of feel
sorry that they live this lifestyle
sorry for them that they're sort of
enslaved to these religious rules I feel
sorry for them that they have to
struggle with big issues like accepting
homosexuality in the family for example
and their Church teaches them that this
is an abomination and it's so ingrained
in them but I know they must struggle
feeling like but but I love this person
how could that person be an abomination
those I feel sorry for the the
completely religiously inundated that
that pity for you to like they would
look at you and go well she doesn't have
these incredibly powerful beliefs oh
yeah my dad thinks I'm not going to
heaven
yeah like well yeah exactly and not
especially not the celestial and the
terrestrial heaven gets super
complicated in the Mormon faith right
but yeah of course he feels sorry for me
he thinks I'm not gonna bathe in God's
glory for all of eternity that's like a
pretty big deal to somebody who actually
believes that exist and you're not doing
it just as a private person you're doing
it is very very publicly and EE and
interacting with a lot of people and
potentially influencing people and you
know it's
I'm a heretic and that's you know
probably not something he's very proud
of